في الخامس والعشرين من يوليو 2021 الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد يصدر سلسله قرارات
استثنائيه اعلن بموجبها اقاله الحكومه
برئاسه هشام المشاشي وتجميد عمل البرلمان
برئاسه راشد الغنوشي لمده شهر في الرابع
والعشرين من اغسطس 2021 اعلن سعيد تجميد
عمل البرلمان حتى اشعار اخر واصفا اياه
بالخطر على الدوله في التاسع والعشرين من
سبتمبر 2021 الرئيس سعيد يكلف نجلاء بدن
بتشكيل الحكومه في الثالثه عشر من ديسمبر
من العام نفسه سعيد يعني باستمرار تجميد
عمل البرلمان حتى تنظيم الانتخابات من
تشريعيه جديده في السابعه عشر من ديسمبر
يناير 2022 ارتفاع بين الخارجي لتونس الى
41 مليار دولار ما يشكل نحو 83% من الناتج
المحلي في الخامس من فبراير الماضي سعيد
يعلنو حل المجلس الاعلى للقضاء بعد ان
اتهم اعضاءا فيه بالفساد والولاء لحركه
النهضه في ال30 من مارسي الماضي وبعد
ساعات قليله على عقد البرلمان المعلق جلسه
عامه افتراضيه واصدره قانونا يلغي كل
اجراءات سعيد الاستثنائيه الرئيس يقرر حلل
مجلس النيابي معتبرا ان ذلك القرار جاء
للحفاظ على الشعب ومؤسسات الدوله في
الثانيه والعشرين من ابريل سعيد يصدر امرا
رئاسيا لتعديل القانون الاساسي وتركيبه
الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات ليصبح
مجلس الهيئه مكونه من سبعه اعضاء يتم
تعيينهم بامر رئاسي في التاسعه عشر من
مايو الماضي بس عيدي يصدر مرسوما الرئاسيه
بتشكيل هيئه الوطنيه الاستشاريه من اجل
جمهوريه جديده والتي من مهامها انجازه دست
جديد للبلاد في الحادي والثلاثين من الشهر
نفسه قوانت تونسيه معارضه للرئيس تعلن
تكوين جبهه باسم الخلاص الوطني برئاسه
احمد الشابي في الثلاثين من يوليو الرئيس
سعيد ينشر مشروع الدستور الجديد الذي سيتم
الاستفتاء عليه بعد ذلك باربعه ايام رئيس
الهيئه الوطنيه الاستشاريه المكلفه بصياغه
الدستور الصادق بالعيد يتبرا من مشروع
الدستور ويعتبر انه يمهد لنظام
الديكتاتوريه
في الخامسه والعشرين من يوليو التصويت على
مشروع الدستور الجديد بمشاركه نحو 27% من
من يحق لهم التصويت واربعه 94%
يصوطون بنعم سبتمبر 2022 الحكومه التونسيه
ترفع اسعار غاز الطهي والوقود والاسواق
تشهد ندره في مواد استهلاكيه اساسيه
للسكر والحليب والزيت النباتي
نوفمبر 2022 مدن تونسيه تشهد زياده لافته
في عدد الاحتجاجات المهدده بالاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاتحاد العام للشغل يحذر من
انفجار اجتماعي ال17 من ديسمبر 2022 بدا
الاقتراعي في اول انتخابات تشريعيه وفق
الدستور الجديد